we have one more video
in our series of a pro-abortion person
making all of the arguments that the
pro-abortion people supposedly need to
make to persuade pro-lifers to stop
defending life this is from aaron who's
a nurse calls herself a leftist a
deconstructee evangelical whatever that
means has pronouns in her bios i
actually think her videos have been
relatively good pro-lifers legitimately
think abortion is murder they see the
fetus as a child there are many people
in my dad's situation who could have
survived is it murder if i pull the plug
they're not making really strong
arguments but she is at least
identifying arguments
that pro-abortion people make two
pro-lifers that are not persuasive she
seems to be implying that the arguments
are not persuasive because pro-lifers
are just closed-minded or shut off but
regardless she's at least taking the
pro-lifers somewhat seriously so let's
see how she rounds out her arguments
okay if you are going to have a debate
with the pro-lifer and you want it to go
well and you don't want it to derail
please don't ever tell them that a fetus
is the clump of cells you can think it
don't say it if you start from the
process it's just a clump of cells then
you're not going to go anywhere but i
think the operative word there is just a
fetus is a clump of cells and a
five-year-old is a clump of cells and
you and i are clumps of cells
if we were just clumps of cells there
would be no
morality
regarding whether or not to kill us even
the idea of killing us wouldn't make a
lot of sense we are clumps of cells
materially but we are animated
spiritually we have a soul we have
dignity we have faculties of reason we
can use those faculties of reason to
think about the objective moral order
and ethics and how we should behave and
whether or not we should kill each other
whether in the womb or outside of the
womb so we are kinds of clumps of cells
but we're more than clumps of cells as
well and so the libs get that first part
right but they fail to recognize the
intrinsic value of human beings which is
where the debate is which i think is
what she's getting another thing you
never want to say out loud is that their
religion is dictating their views on
being pro-life because they see abortion
as murder and that's not just a
christian take that's not just a
catholic or
a religious take people in society
generally agree that murder is wrong
so she's right generally speaking it
will be unpersuasive if pro-abortion
people just say you just you're just
letting your religion dictate your views
but as a matter of fact
yes religion is dictating my views
it is in fact i i supported abortion for
10 years i'm not all that actively i
didn't i was not like i was campaigning
for abortion or you know
supporting planned parenthoods or
anything i just didn't really think
about it i grew up in a liberal place
most of my friends were liberal didn't
even occur to me that pro-life
was something to be taken seriously
from the moment that i confronted an
actual pro-lifer and she gave me the
arguments for pro-life it knocked down
all of my abortion arguments it is
certainly
the case that later on i realized
retrospectively all of this is religious
at the time i would have said i'm
pro-life because of science you only
believe in science all human conflict
ultimately is religious she says well no
it's not just christians who believe
it's wrong to commit murder
that's true yeah every sane person
throughout history is known as wrong to
commit murder that's still a religious
view it comes to us from the natural law
it comes to us from the precepts of
morality that we can
we can know just naturally through our
conscience and through our faculties of
reason that is still religious whether
we are aware of that or not there's more
from this lady to get to in one second
first though you got to go to
goodranchers.com
knowles president ronald reagan famously
said all great change in america begins
at the dinner table we'll bring your
family to the dinner table with good
ranchers these guys are the best they
ship 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the united states right to
your door they age every cut to
perfection they give you the true
steakhouse experience right in your own
home the quality simply cannot be beat
when you subscribe i'm not joking your
price is locked in for life we're at a
time of crazy inflation going through
the roof and somehow you're going to
lock in your meat prices for life these
guys are wonderful i eat good ranchers
probably three times a week at this
point i love their products their
chicken their beef their burgers their
steaks all of it is so phenomenal use my
code no scanner wlas to get your
steakhouse experience for 30 bucks off
plus free shipping on your order
shipping is not cheap this is a lot of
top quality meat so take advantage of
this offer go to goodranchers.com
knowles these guys are the best start
bringing people back to the table and
eating seriously delicious food have you
already bought from good ranchers good
show me what you're making post a photo
of your meal tag me and my friends over
at goodranchers so they can see it too
all right back to this lady the reality
is and you'd think this don't say this
the reality is is that was their
starting point so they were
indoctrinated into this view that a
fetus is a whole person i myself
included this was my starting point so
if you are going to actively be in
conversation and your goal is to try to
get them to see your side you have to
realize that you're not you're both not
starting at the same point you're both
not neutral on this they are already so
far ahead in the direction of the fetus
as a whole person that you have to
slowly bring them into this reality that
maybe they maybe they're not right maybe
this isn't a whole person yes it's true
you're starting with different premises
and so she's saying they're so they're
so far down the line they believe the
thing that that
is true they're so far down the line
they believe the thing that most people
have believed for all of human history
that a baby is a baby but we we're we're
the rational people we know that a baby
is not a baby but to somehow magically
becomes a baby at some unknown point
that we can't quite figure out what
you're really saying is people begin
with different premises so then you've
got to figure out who's starting with
the correct premises
is the baby a baby or is the baby not a
baby
and it's not just preference it's not
just you like chocolate and i like
vanilla and degustibus non-disputan de
mest you know there's no there's there's
no accounting or debating taste those
premises are making objective statements
and we can decide which statements are
true and which statements are false
either the baby's a baby or the baby's
not a baby one of you is right and one
of you is wrong
and we can figure out which one is right
and which one is wrong by
looking at a sonogram by looking at dna
by looking at the characteristics of
life that the baby does in fact have by
analyzing aspects of moral reasoning
i say is it
is it right or wrong to commit murder
you can answer these questions with a
high degree of accuracy because the the
premises are statements of fact in fact
statements of fact are going to be true
or false you need to start poking holes
in the reality that that's a whole human
if you can successfully get to the point
where they start questioning that a
fetus is an actual
person
then you can start having productive
conversations about the overall negative
impact that restricting abortion has
yes she's right if you can convince a
pro-lifer that a baby is not really a
baby then actually you don't she she's
not being ambitious enough then you
don't really need to have a conversation
about the
negative impact of a pregnancy that on a
woman you don't have you can just
if you can convince a pro-lifer that a
baby is not really a baby it's not
really a human person
then they'll just support abortion the
thing is you're you're not going to
convince the pro-lifer that the baby is
not a baby because the baby is a baby
and once you see it
it's it's very rare that you can unsee
it very very few people move from
pro-life to pro-abortion this woman says
that she did i'm not sure having watched
her videos i'm not sure her grasp on
what pro-lifers actually think is all
that great it's better than most
pro-abortion people but it's it's not
it's not all that strong i'm not sure
that her conviction on pro-life was was
rooted all that deeply before she
convinced herself that she's
pro-abortion maybe as this woman's
trying to poke holes in the premises of
pro-life maybe if she analyzes them more
deeply maybe she'll realize that the far
bigger holes are in her own premises
like maternal mortality rate or
overpopulation
overpopulation see now she's getting
into all these utilitarian arguments and
even if it is a baby never mind you know
overpopulation lump that one away with
the boogeyman that is not real the libs
were warning of overpopulation back in
1970 there was a very famous
best-selling book called the population
bomb it said that within 10 years even
if we dramatically reduce population
size there's going to be famine it's
going to be disaster because of the
overpopulation you know what's happened
since then it's been over 50 years since
that book came out the world population
has doubled not only did we not get the
mass famines within 10 years we haven't
gotten them ever actually malnutrition
is in an all-time low
it was totally fake and it led to lots
of terrible things
those arguments and that book led to
a coerced sterilization especially of
poor women in places like india in china
led to the one child policy it led to
all
forced abortions and the pro abortion
people called for this they said if
you're not going to convince people
voluntarily to sterilize themselves and
use contraceptives and get abortions
we'll have to force them to do that and
it was based on a completely
false
debunked premise abortion clinics are
closing down for
uh people who need abortions for
non-viable fetuses miscarriages no one
needs an abortion
you've heard this argument cropping up
recently women who have miscarriages
need abortions that is a nonsensical
statement that doesn't mean anything an
abortion a procured abortion is when you
kill a living baby in the womb
by definition a miscarriage is when a
baby dies in the womb so the removal of
a miscarriage
is not abortion it cannot be a procured
abortion the confusion arises because
before the pro-abortion movement the
term for miscarriage was spontaneous
abortion spontaneous just the the
pregnancy was aborted and that happens
that happens in
to a lot of people sadly the
pro-abortion movement then sort of
monopolizes this term and says when you
go in and actively kill a baby in the
womb that's what an abortion is but you
can't actively kill a baby who has died
from a miscarriage because the baby's
already dead you've seen these memes all
over social media right you've seen
memes
you've seen these memes that's her best
argument not a science book not an
ethics book not a medical doctor it's uh
you've seen memes right people are
posting all of these things and you're
thinking oh a pro-lifer's gonna read
that and be like oh gosh you know maybe
i really need to change my stance
no you have to start with you have to
convince them that abortion is not
murder they're going to see all of these
memes everywhere and it's it doesn't
matter to them because they they think
you they think we're totally immoral the
people who are really gung-ho about
abortion
tend to be pretty immoral and the things
that the abortion supporters are doing
are objectively immoral but i don't
think of people who support abortion as
necessarily immoral just because of that
they might just be ignorant i ignorantly
supported abortion for
my teenage years until i gave it even
two seconds thought i actually don't
walk around just thinking you awful
terrible person i very often i think oh
you ignorant person or you person who
hasn't been like me had has not yet been
exposed to the arguments for pro-life
but it's not you know
i would i would drop the victimhood
mentality here it's not that the
pro-lifers are so terribly judgmental of
the horrible state of your soul and the
immoral actions that you are knowingly
willfully committing it's just that
you're wrong
and
frequently in your ignorance you're
committing terrible acts and you've got
to cut it out can you bring them to the
reality that abortion's not murder then
they can start objectively seeing all
the negative impact the health impact
what we see as healthcare workers why
abortion is so
central and so necessary for a thriving
healthy society so obviously it's not
killing babies is not good for a healthy
society lots of societies have believed
that it is i mean that's what eugenics
is that you see that going all the way
back to ancient sparta and lots of
people sacrificing their babies to their
gods and the ancient middle east and now
we sacrifice our babies to our gods in
modernity the gods of career or money or
convenience or anything else the more
things change the more things stay the
same you are right if you can convince
pro-lifers that the baby is not a baby
and that abortion is not morally similar
to murder or the equivalent of murder
then they would support abortion you're
not going to be successful in doing that
and the reason you're not going to be
successful in convincing the pro-lifers
that their premise is wrong is because
the premise is correct before sonogram
technology it was more difficult to see
what was going on in the womb but we
know we can see
that the moment of conception is really
a moment it's when the sperm and the egg
come together instantly and then you get
this new individual life with all the
characteristics of life so the more that
we learn scientifically medically and
the more we think
ethically philosophically theologically
the less strong the argument for any
abortion becomes the much stronger the
pro-life argument becomes and so now
that we've gone through aaron's
arguments maybe she can go through my
arguments and i hope that i persuade her
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you